الأشياء التي عبروا عنها في
الاحتجاج كانت مفاجأة لنا تمامًا
لأن الشيء الذي كان مصدر قلق في البداية
كان بناء المسجد ولكن
ما فعلوه في الاحتجاجات لم يكن
متعلقًا ببناء مسجد
كان له علاقة بديننا
[موسيقى]
لم يكن الضجيج شيئًا
متعلقًا بالصلاة لأنك سترى أنه
عندما نصلي نحن المسلمون ،
يجب على شخص واحد فقط أن يتكلم مع الآخرين يجب أن يتبعه
بغض النظر عما إذا كان من مئات الأشخاص إلى 100 شخص ،
ولكن ما زلنا
نضمن لهم أنه إذا  الضوضاء هي
المشكلة سنقوم بتشغيل
جدران عازلة للصوت ونوافذ عازلة للصوت
أجنبية
[موسيقى]
أنا هنا كممثل لمجتمع طلاب مسلمين كنو
ويتألف المجتمع من أكثر أو أقل من
150 طالبًا مسلمًا هذا المكان ليس
بعضًا  مكان جديد لنا لأننا
كنا نصلي هنا منذ سبع
سنوات والآن بعد الشعور بالحاجة
إليها لأن الطلاب المسلمين
أكبر عددًا
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
[موسيقى  ]
[موسيقى
] إذا كان الطلاب المسلمون يأتون إلى هنا ،
أعتقد أنه يجب أيضًا مراعاة الاحتياجات الروحية لهؤلاء
الطلاب المسلمين
كما لو كان هناك ملعب كرة قدم
لي حيث يمكنني تلبية
احتياجاتي البدنية ، فيجب أن يكون هناك
أيضًا مكان يمكنني فيه ذلك  تلبية احتياجاتي الدينية
الأجنبية
[موسيقى]